I am currently the co-chair for the
Institute for Research in African
American Studies Alumni Council and so
what we do is we connect current
graduates to current undergraduates and
we develop programs, we align them and
create a network and a source for them
to think about their work and their
professions outside of the Academy and
outside of their time here at Columbia
but we also support the Institute for
Research and African American Studies in
terms of supporting their programs and
aligning them with current and past
alumni. The work that I did at
Columbia during my time here is
essential to the work that I'm doing now
I work on Shirley Chisholm, that was my
master's thesis, which I received the Zora Neale Hurston Award, and I was a
Paul Robeson fellow here and so it was
essential, it set the groundwork for the
work that I do now, I'm currently the
director of the Shirley Chisholm Project
for Brooklyn women's activism at
Brooklyn College, I am a loan expert
around Shirley Chisholm and black
woman's politics and so it was essential
for the ways in which I think about
black women and politics
it started the groundwork for my current
manuscript called "Sister Insider/ Sister
Outsider," a comparative study of shirley
Chisholm and Barbara Jordan and the
black women's politics in the post-civil
rights era and so it allowed me to get
the feedback from faculty on how to
think about writing, how to approach a
theoretical framework for the work that
I  do on black women